hey guys it's justine and today we're
gonna be doing my top favorite pieces of
tech that i've covered on my channel in
2020 but before we get into that a huge
thank you to today's video sponsor
zen zen is a really new and interesting
form of making
and accepting payments online now it's
great not only for personal use but for
businesses as well
they have found a way to fight the chaos
that can come from online shopping and
being a store owner it's a shopping cart
that connects with the zen app that
allows you to make online and offline
payments
in over a hundred and fifty currencies
with zero fees for exchange rates on
transactions made in your account's
currency
you can get a physical and virtual card
as you can see here this is my account
with my virtual card attached to it
if anything ever doesn't work out with a
transaction like you receive a broken
product or
you don't even receive the item at all
zen will take care of the issue for you
they call this a part of their benefits
they also give you an automatic one-year
extended warranty on any electronics you
purchase when you pay with your zen card
and there's also zero fees when shopping
at foreign retailers like aliexpress or
amazon
in another country now for business
owners it's able to act as a payment
platform for e-commerce so what's really
awesome
is as soon as someone pays you the money
ends up on your account within seconds
and it's ready to use they also don't
take a markup for processing payments
and they have a zero charge back so if
one does happen zen will take care of it
i'll put a link in the description if
you want to download the zen
app and you can get four months free but
if you're a business owner you can also
get an additional two months free check
it out and let me know what you guys
think
and now for the top 20 pieces of tech
that i've covered here on my channel in
this list is not ranked in any order i
went through made my list and then i
sorted them alphabetically so i didn't
have to choose one through 20 but
the irony is the number one thing that
is on this list
alphabetically is the a7s3
which i guess if i had to choose that
would be pretty appropriate
that's the number one piece of tech and
i'm shooting on it right now
[Music]
this camera has pretty much changed the
way that we've shot videos it's been so
incredible and ever since we got it
well i got three of them so that's
saying something it has made our lives
so much better right tyler
oh yeah next on the list alphabetically
is ibo do you remember ibo the dog the
freaking sony dog
jenna actually got this in the mail from
sony and she named it stella
so we're at lunch right now and stella
and mango are meeting
although everyone says they haven't
fallen off the table yet no i'm actually
really impressed
when they're going forward they know
because they have two sensors on the
chest and then one sensor on the nose
they understand
they're on out on the surface hi mango
you good boy
[Music]
do you have anything for robot dogs
don't sell a real food you can't have
look this is real food this is what your
brother eats
well this brand that was such a fun
video we went and hung out with farooq
and his dog
mango mango such a cute name stella and
mango they had a great time together and
number three on the list
any guesses you guessed right it's the
airpods max
[Music]
ear cups off speechless
oh it's such a nice
fit this next piece of tech has saved me
so much money in postmates this is the
brava oven
thing has completely honestly actually
changed my life good morning
it's time for breakfast my favorite part
about this is the fact that this oven
has a camera inside of it so what i do a
lot of times is i will make my sandwich
i will go up and take a shower really
quick and i will keep
the live camera open to see how much
time i have left so i can keep showering
and get down here just enough time for
my sandwich to be done
this thing cooks with infrared light
it's so fast it's so efficient
and it made someone who doesn't like to
cook
cook next up is the hp envy all-in-one
and i absolutely
love this it's basically like an imac
but it's a pc
this features 32 gigs of ram one
terabyte solid state drive and
nvidia geforce gtx 1650 graphics card it
has a 10th gen
intel core i7 2.9 gigahertz processor
that redefines what's possible in a thin
and light computer
and why i love this so much is i've used
it for so many different things i now
use this as my second streaming computer
i use it for our podcasts
this was such a fun video to make and
next the insta360
one x2 what's really cool about this is
the selfie stick will be removed in post
so automatically
it'll just kind of look like this thing
is floating in midair are they already
put together
yeah okay so like if i got this right
now i could ride it like out i think i'd
break it
the mini probably it's meant for up to
five year olds 50 kilograms
so like 125. okay i'll just get this one
[Music]
i also got a really cool scooter in that
video so the next
the next thing that we have on the list
is the iphone 12
and that's just the iphone 12 like i
mean there's four of them can i put four
under there
12 12 mini 12 pro 12 pro max all four of
[Music]
them
oh lego super mario is up next this is
probably one of my favorite videos this
year when we turned my entire living
room into a lego super mario course
[Music]
remember when apple announced their new
m1 chips and then came out with
three all-new computers yep next on the
list
the m1 max today we are taking a look at
the first new mac devices with the brand
new m1 chip
we have the new macbook air the macbook
pro 13-inch
and the mac mini m1 is apple's first
chip in their family of chips that are
being built in-house that will slowly
over the next two years
replace intel this is really a step in
an incredible direction for apple and
i'm very excited to test these out
further
and really just see what we can push the
limits to on all three of these there's
a macbook air macbook pro on mac mini
that's scary yeah
that counts as one that kind of counts
this one the ipad pro magic keyboard is
next the magic keyboard kind of
reinvented the way that i use
my ipad i started editing on my ipad and
since now the whole world was
kind of shifting around and changing the
way that we work i started using my ipad
so much more than ever before
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
remember at the start of quarantine when
the first drone
came out and i was reviewing the mavic
air 2 and i was like how am i supposed
to do a drone review because i can't
leave my house
well we did it and also r.i.p curtains
and then i'll fly it a little bit in the
house i do have some prop guards for it
so just in case i hit the walls or
anything just in case i hit the walls
for anything
i gotta turn obstacle avoidance
[Music]
so we can fly free free
[Applause]
2020 was also the year of new consoles
and alphabetically
speaking the playstation 5 is up next
and i've actually been playing the
playstation 5
a lot
[Music]
also this year my sister and i started a
podcast if you haven't heard of it
before it's called same
brain and this piece of tech for us
has changed the way that not only
podcasts but also my entire gaming setup
revolves around this this is the road
caster pro
extremely exciting one of my favorite
things about podcasting is pushing the
buttons on the road caster pro
and since this is ours now we can set
those up to be whatever we want we can
have our own sounds
so what do you do when you can't go to
starbucks every day like you did before
oh that's right you make coffee at home
like you probably
should this is the spin coffee maker and
this is an all new way to make coffee
espresso
all with an app on your phone this is
something that has been in development
for many years it started out as a
kickstarter and now over five years
later it is finally shipping to
customers and what's exciting about this
is they have perfected an all-new way of
making coffee
why this is called spin is because the
beans are actually spinning inside of
this machine
instead of being pressed down smells
so i know
[Music]
also what do you do when you can't go to
the gym anymore because all of the gyms
are closed
you bring the gym to you
[Music]
this is the tempo studio it's an
all-in-one home gym that takes
performance tracking to a whole new
level
and it's the only system that gives you
instant feedback to improve your form it
uses 3d motion sensors and ai to analyze
your movements and count your reps
weight lifted calories burned and more
as you progress
it will increase your weight
recommendations and customize the
programming to help fit your fitness
goals
[Music]
this was such a fun piece of tech that i
got this year because i'd never really
done much strength training before but
with this it's a way to kind of give you
guided exercises and feedback from the
trainers
and alphabetically the next piece of
tech
is also something that was quite
unexpected for 2020
uh tom green's van we're getting ready
to take off into the wild
uh in in our new van charlie and i just
got this new van boho
that's the name of their company they
were on shark tank no way this is a
ram promaster van and they take and they
convert it into a camper
and is this all custom then you told
them what you wanted they kind of have
been doing this so
in a lot of ways i kind of like to let
them take the lead because they know
what they're doing but you know we i did
make a few adjustments to certain things
for my studio and stuff and i'm
recording my album my comedy country rap
album i call it
uh comedy country wrap it's crap i'm
smiling but you can't see it
it's under there it'll be fun justine
you want to see my 25 gallon water tank
yeah yeah it's nice right that's nice
that's it
that's mine i also got a chance to check
out this really cool bike by specialized
[Music]
definitely found myself riding my bike
way more this year than ever before
because i was spending more time at home
and not traveling
so being able to get out and go for a
really quick bike ride was something
that i'm so grateful for this year
speaking of grateful next up we have the
xbox
series x and series s now not only did i
get
both of those consoles this year i also
got an xbox refrigerator and they
only made three of these
look at this i'm gonna put my controller
in the
in there it's something we did
[Music]
the next to the last thing on the list
is the samsung
z-flip this has been such a cool phone
yes i know the z-fold also came out this
year but there is something about that
z-flip
that is just so satisfying to flip open
[Music]
and last but not least is the sony's ev1
and this little vlogging camera is
something that we have all been waiting
for for a very long time
it has the flip out screen it has
incredible audio small
compact is everything that we have
wanted in a small
portable compact sony vlogging camera
this is the sony
zv1 comes with a microphone windscreen
micro usb cable
battery and the camera
and a flip-out screen
[Music]
i've been keeping a checklist for the
things that i have been looking for in a
vlogging camera and this
camera right here checks almost every
single one of those boxes
thank you guys so much for watching this
video and also supporting my channel
this entire year i know this year has
been so crazy
for everyone but i'm so grateful that
i've been able to still make videos for
you guys and keep you guys entertained
it's also been really fun doing live
streams i did start doing that this year
and thank you also for supporting our
podcast it's kind of been fun to sort of
get into these new things that i never
would have had the chance to have done
before so hopefully you guys at home
have also found some new hobbies or
something to keep yourself occupied and
entertained during this wild year
i can't believe that 2020 is almost over
let's cross our fingers and hope that
2021 is much better and
i will see you guys in the next video
which will probably be tomorrow or the
next day you can't ever be
really too sure here on my inconsistent
channel
[Music]